deby est mort vive débit ce mercredi le
fils de l'ex-président tchadien décédé
la veille des suites de ses blessures au
front a chaussé les bottes de son père
mahamat idriss déby jeune général de 37
ans occupe désormais les fonctions de
président de la république du tchad chef
de l'état et chef suprême des armées
le tout à la tête d'un conseil militaire
de transition de quinze généraux mis en
place pour au moins 18 mois
pour l'opposition qui critique est déjà
vivement la longévité de dés qui perd
cette succession ne passe pas condamne
avec fermeté institutionnels opéré par
les généraux après la mort du président
de la république
cela ressemble à un coup d'état
et ça ne devrait pas être un coup d'état
et par conséquent il fallait tout
simplement mettre en jeu les mécanismes
optionnels qui existe à savoir la
constitution du tchad
il faut dire que le nouvel homme fort du
tchad n'y va pas par quatre chemins
l'instauration d'un couvre-feu et
fermeture temporaire des frontières
terrestres et aériennes mais surtout
dissolution de l'assemblée nationale et
concentration des pouvoirs
la charte publié ce mercredi prévoit
également que la durée de la transition
gérée par la junte
peut être reconduite une fois le tchad
ne connaîtrai dans ce cas pas
d'élections démocratiques avant trois
ans une situation qui embarrasse les
alliés du tchad paris en tête qu'ils
s'abstiennent de qualifier de coup
d'état cette prise de pouvoir
aujourd'hui une transition commence dans
des conditions dont nous prenons acte
nous espérons qu'elle se déroulera
pacifiquement dans un esprit de dialogue
et de concertation pour aboutir à une
gouvernance civil stable et que la
transition militaire sera la plus brève
possible
la situation est mouvante je n'aurai pas
la caractérise et d'une quelconque
manière à ce stade ce que je répondrai à
votre question et que j'ai déjà dit
c'est que nous encourageons depuis
longtemps les avancées vers la
démocratie et un gouvernement
représentatif au tchad c'est quelque
chose que nous continuerons à faire des
précautions diplomatiques qui s'explique
par le soutien de poids que représente
le tchad dans la lutte contre les
djihadistes au sahel
le qg des forces militaires françaises
barkani est installé et la france avait
en retour bombardé des positions
rebelles au nord du pays en 2019
emmanuel macron doit d'ailleurs assisté
ce vendredi aux obsèques de l'ex
président tchadien
tout comme une dizaine d'autres chefs
d'état